comment produits tongs hydrogène
aujourd'hui et le problème de
l'hydrogène aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça
que l'avion à hydrogène c'est pendant
très longtemps ou l'avion vers c'est
qu'on produit l'hydrogène aujourd'hui
avec des énergies fossiles et donc
l'augmentation de la production
d'hydrogène sa campagne de
d'énergie faustine en fait rêver la
population sur l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène est abondante qu'ils doivent
être gêné par tous et comme
l'électricité c'est la nouvelle fait
alors je veux bien concevoir qu'on soit
scientifique qu'on soit extrêmement
sérieux donc l'avion à hydrogène d'avion
vers l'avion qui serait propre
l'hydrogène et pourquoi pas en aura
sûrement besoin de cet hydrogène la
l'hydrogène qui serait produite avec des
combustibles vert c'est à dire avec du
renouvelable
mais ce n'est pas pour demain y compris
pour la voiture y compris pour la
voiture donc je crois qu'il ne faut pas
faire rêver faire rêver sur des fausses
solutions qui nous éloigne de la prise
en charge aujourd'hui de ce qui nous
arrive parce que ce n'est pas que la
question climatique bien sûr que c'est
la question climatique
c'est tout aussi c'est aussi un monde
totalement mondialisé qui nous ne nous
fait nous nous a exposé à des pollutions
terrible tout à l'heure monsieur disait
je ne veux pas être confinée moi non
plus je ne pas être confinée
certainement pas et justement j'estime
que si nous sommes confinés aujourd'hui
c'est le résultat d'une mondialisation
phone d'une comment dire oui d'une
globalisation fold d'eau l'aviation est
un des éléments pas le seul mais dans
l'aviation en tout cas a été le sous
bassement matérielles alors je voudrais
dire aussi monsieur 80% de la population
mondiale n'a jamais pris l'avion et je
n'ai méprise pas comme des gens qui
seraient confinés nous qu'ils y aurions
accès tout à coup à la civilisation
parce que nous serions dans les airs je
crois qu'au contraire nous devons
absolument revenir sur terre en france
20% de la population n'a jamais pris
l'avion
c'est 50% des vols aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont le fruit de deux pour cent de la
population française en france donc
glee
inégalité absolument monstrueuse
concernant la concernant la vienne
concernant l'utilisation usage de
l'avion
[Musique]